economía en france 24 en el estudio se
encuentra daniel hablando con daniela
buena noche bienvenida reino unido le
puso el ultimátum al acuerdo comercial
post exit daniela raúl muy buenas noches
así es lo hizo el primer ministro boris
johnson justo antes de que este martes
se inicie la octava ronda de
negociaciones desde un principio se
sabía que este divorcio entre reino
unido y la unión europea no iba a ser
nada fácil pero pocos se habrían
imaginado que después de siete rondas de
conversaciones hubiera un avance
prácticamente nulo aspectos tan álgidos
como la pesca han impedido un consenso y
si esto no se da antes del 31 de
diciembre el comercio bilateral de
900.000 millones de dólares al año se
verá sumido en la incertidumbre no tiene
sentido pensar en plazos que vayan más
allá del 15 de octubre si no nos ponemos
de acuerdo para entonces no creo que
vaya a haber un acuerdo de libre
comercio entre nosotros y deberíamos
aceptarlo y pasar la página y la unión
europea- raúl no tardó en responderle al
ministro
si bien estamos decididos a llegar a un
acuerdo con el reino unido- la unión
europea estará lista en caso de que se
produzca un escenario sin acuerdo para
comerciar con el reino unido- según los
términos políticos a partir del primero
de enero de 2021
daniele continuamos con más tema porque
estados unidos y méjico entra en un
desacuerdo comercial de qué se trata
raúl todo comenzó cuando hace una semana
la administración de donald trump se
mostró bastante preocupada por que las
importaciones de alimentos perecederos
están afectando a sus productores
locales y apunto a méxico como uno de
los culpables la oficina del
representante comercial estadounidense
dijo que mantendrá conversaciones de
alto nivel con este país durante los
próximos 90 días para abordar justamente
estas preocupaciones sobre todo en
productos como fresas pimientos morrones
y otros productos de temporada mexicanas
esto daría paso a la investigación para
restringir posiblemente estas compras ya
raúl el consejo nacional agropecuario de
méxico rechazó esta medida y dijo que se
defenderá con acciones legales si es
necesario pues cree que violaría las
normas dispuestas en el tema
que recordemos acaba de entrar en
vigencia así es a nivel y las
exportaciones chinas subieron en agosto
por tercer mes consecutivo pues así como
el mayor exportador del mundo fue el
primer país en registrar casos de
coronavirus también es uno de los pocos
que tiene esperanzas de crecer
económicamente este año mientras casi
todo el resto del mundo está en recesión
en marzo según estadísticas oficiales
las ventas al exterior habían caído 35
por ciento por la pandemia pero desde
entonces comenzaron una senda de
crecimiento que las llevó a repuntar en
más del 8% en abril como se puede
observar en este gráfico raúl ya en
agosto lo hicieron en 95 por ciento
impulsadas por equipos médicos y por
productos electrónicos lo que sí está
cayendo son las importaciones debido a
que la demanda interna pues no está tan
fuerte
así es daniela genital investigan a tres
grandes tecnológicas cuáles y cuáles son
las empresas bueno son google apple y
dropbox lo que pretende esta
investigación es esclarecer si estas
empresas han cometido prácticas
comerciales desleales
se han incluido cláusulas abusivas en
sus condiciones contractuales la norma
dice que cuando un usuario decidió usar
aplicaciones de almacenamiento en la
nube debe expresar su consentimiento
para que éstas usen sus datos personales
con fines comerciales pero la autoridad
antimonopolio de italia teme que no se
está cumpliendo esta condición el otro
aspecto que está en la mira raúl es el
caso particular de dropbox que es
supuestamente omite información a la
hora de que los usuarios quieran poner
fin a su contrato de almacenamiento
danielle indicadores como cerraron las
fuerzas las bolsas hoy inicio de semana
bueno las bolsas europeas tuvieron alzas
importantes sin la referencia del
mercado de nueva york que permaneció
encerrado por ser día festivo y a pesar
de las cifras decepcionantes de
producción industrial en alemania en
américa latina las bolsas empezaron la
semana con signos positivos en especial
argentina que lo hizo en más del 1% raúl
y para finalizar que nos trae como cifra
el día son los 2,7 millones de euros
que el príncipe harry devolvió a la
familia real británica
este dinero había sido invertido raúl en
las reformas de su residencia en las
inmediaciones del castillo de windsor en
el reino unido y aunque estos recursos
pues salieron de las arcas nacionales
harris se comprometió a pagar los de su
propio bolsillo tras abandonar la
monarquía con su esposa megan mar coll
hace aproximadamente seis meses así es
daniela muchísimas gracias por toda la
información ustedes también gracias
continuamos con nosotros
[Música]